good morning night city yesterday i'm
turning on the camera the lottery routed
out to a solid and sturdy
30 10 out of haywood thanks to unabated
gang wars
one officer down so i guess you're all
screwed
cause the ncpd will not let that go
got another blackout in santo domingo
net runners are at it again
poke and holes i've never seen this
while over in westbrook trauma teams
scraping
cyber psycho victims of the pavement
and in pacifica well
pacifica is still pacifica
this has been your man there he is join
me for another day in our
city of dreams all right
it's another day
hey everyone feels great to have you
back i need to go back to my house
because apparently there's a sword in
there that i never picked up
there it is
hey go to liz's bar
between 6 p.m and 6 a.m oh there's a
time where's the time it's 6 p.m at 10
p.m right now so now
hey don't [ __ ] hit me that was so
close
can you fast travel in this game
where's my house
track job jump
to the
apparently i level up i've been going
full out on blades
because i'm epic like that
recover health oh that might be good all
right let's call our car
there she is
i have to drive all the way
oh god this is scary
[Music]
so what is the consensus on the game i i
heard it's quite mixed
god damn these things stairs
all right yeah let me remove the border
yeah i like this song too
[Music]
yeah it seems like the bugs is ruined
for a lot of people but
for some reason i don't really mind it
just makes it funny to play
oh we're going here hello
hello all right
liz's bar let me just turn up this frame
thing
ah should i move myself
maybe bottom is that better
shouldn't cover up anything here
what up ladies a little put out there
input
interest you in a prem bd what the [ __ ]
is a bd
sure and i go hold it house rules first
there will be severe penalties for any
unauthorized recording
no drugs no groping that's right i'm not
live streaming or anything
you do not grab them you find them in
the catalog
ask for a bd and get yourself a box i
really look that green to you
like i don't know
doors open have fun input
welcome to lizzy's
i'm married by the way okay i don't
doing this my what a sweet little face
you have
thank you oh
hey
yeah what's up in the big world
you tell me big girl
whoa that's bigger than i expected
talk to girl at desk a few times for a
meme well
all right uh what's your guy he's my
dead spunk
thank you will thank you
my what a sweet little face you have
kiss my dead spunk that's
[Music]
copyright is off relax
this world is so vast and so detailed
kiss my tits bug
hey
what up get you something
i hate getting drunk in games it just
blurs everything it's not fun uh looking
for everything evelyn parker
you know she's here who's asking
name's v she and i have a uh date
well v it's a pleasure i'm a dale uh-huh
so evelyn glove's big we're gonna have
to look around
and do it for you it's all right mateo
she looks like the girl from
the spotless mind movie or whatever yeah
except an actual prostitute
i'm not drinking why not say hello soon
i wanted to get a good look at you first
and like what you see
if i didn't rest assured you'd know
come on no place we can talk where ears
won't prick up to listen
[Music]
we'll be in the lounge he's talking
about you [ __ ]
[Music]
what what the [ __ ] what are you guys
looking at
you want to like things
[Music]
why don't you just tell me the truth
whoa that's cool
dex had a load to say about you called
you professional effective
and trustworthy i hope he wasn't
overselling
oh so if i had more whatever that is i
could use that you don't give a rat's
dick
what dex thinks we both know that
you have trouble accepting compliments
no
just think flattery's beneath you am i
wrong
i'm looking here maybe dex is beneath
you
have you known each other long
just started working with him in fact
i've heard there are two kinds of fixers
those with stable crews on long
contracts and short leashes
loyalty and predictability they value
above all else
then there's the other kind dex's
kind
uh let's just get let's get downstairs
let's get down to what you got for me
your target i trust you know what it
is relic secure your soul trinket
key tech in the program actually we're
tangling with our soccer
making this house when dangerously
[ __ ]
howdasaka's poured billions into
personality transfer technology
but me i just want the data on this one
the chip is tucked away inside kompecki
plus people think the
story in this game is boring now you
know how i feel every game
i never think the story is gay yeah no
out of my price range
hmm i'll get decors to die for oh you
can
zoom ah so where's this chip hiding
exactly
in a suite on the top floor the room's
occupied by yorinobu arasaka
you're a noble arasaka he's in town
don't you read this yeah
it was all over the headlines anyway
he's heir apparent to the arasaka empire
saburo arasaka's only surviving son
what so arisaka junior's planning to
grab the reigns while in night city
only a handful of people in night city
hey i understand you need a reason to
shoot guys that's all i care about
you're one of them
[Music]
look if you've got any spare aces up
your sleeve now's the time to show them
now this should make your prick perk up
your excuse me swiped the chip from an
arasaka laboratory
he's made a deal with netwatch aims to
sell it to them have you
spotted my ace yet or do i need to spell
things out
fine so no arasaka's security on the
device because yorinobu whisted away in
secret
now where is keanu reeves likely in a
specialized container
one that mimics so are these quests
for the class that i picked and then
once the second arc
begins that's when everyone comes
together
or is it the same for everyone right now
all right okay what's next now comes the
best part
follow me got something for you should
help you plan
brain dance from kompecki plaza how's
the brain dance supposed to help
me facts not thrills i think bds are
only good for
fondling virtual tits excuse me jacking
off too in those boxes
what no it can be a very useful tool
good for analyzing details human
perception
even boosted doesn't grasp exactly what
you need
so what's on the tape yorinobu suite
the glorious interior you'll need to
locate the relic yourself
hope i grabbed enough detail to make
that possible
uh yeah yeah i'll see ya
oh no i don't know would you like
anything else
all right mom it's a bit
relax oh no oh no
no no no no no
no no be ready to look away kids
hold up mean to say you recorded this
bdrak implant why you object
supposed to be your nobu's pat on the
tape
means you were inside you know each
other
how else could i get all this intel i
know him pretty well actually we have
an arrangement strictly business suits
us both i think
let's see this brain dance
[Music]
judy will help she's a mox too
besides we go back uh years
close your ears and look away that's
right
v this is important judy's always been
there for me
always helped out this week for sure
[Music]
believe it or not i'm no stranger to
tagged
oh no oh no
um am i back
sorry game cry obs crashed if only i was
using band camp instead
excuse me
think i can handle it let's just do this
rydo sit down settle in
and we'll get you going
no no i will not sip
i will not no i said no
is this sanitized it doesn't look clean
no
all right flashing light warning
apparently
gotta create your sensory profile first
okay hit me just promise me
you should look away regardless not this
time
look at my little shoes still look at me
i'm gonna run the analysis soft [ __ ]
feel a slight tingle
i'm looking at her okay now let's set
the optics and other sensory sticks
look smack into these two screens
pretend it's an eye exam
am i gonna have to do this calibration
dance every time
not necessarily but it's worth the wait
give me two more minutes and you'll see
exactly what bd analysis is capable of
one more sec need to get the pain
receptor limiters in
okay all set you need to test your
profile
first tossing in a sample beauty
look at my little toes now let me see
so cute
can't he just use my recording why are
we wasting time
so we don't risk our necks besides won't
take a sec
got something here it should be perfect
yeah they just want an excuse to show
titties
i know what they're doing
be diving in three two one
plan simple do nothing odd don't get
creative you go in
what the [ __ ] is this get out and we
sell the bd to those psycho freaks from
the studio
got it got it and remember everything on
full blast they'll spot us extra for a
wicked adrenaline high
okay on you go
this ain't i'm actually disappointed
everybody autograph what i see you
kissing the flooring
money now yeah drop your sword
whoa yeah now
before i blow your [ __ ] head off
slow deep breaths your cortisol and
adrenaline spiked but the soft activated
your hormone blockers nothing happened
you're alive and well
that flash of intense shock
i can still feel it i remember
[ __ ] that last second
you could have warned me how much it
hurts to die trust me
real death hurts much much more not so
sure about that
you'll be fine all right this is a bit
drag set up come on
let's switch over to editing mode
i'll sever the link to the vd roller's
sensory array
you'll be able to look around freely
whole scene's yours
think of it as your own little sandbox
so analysis mode
you control playback what's up when you
feel the need
then you use the editor console
give it a try rewind
all good neat now try fast forwarding a
bit
that's simple do nothing odd don't get
creative
you're going
you can also reset the recording that'll
take you right back to the beginning
try it now for some fun this here's why
you came in finally
thank you in analysis mode you get to
view and even scan
details of the enviro recorded by the bd
roller
focus on the heat the gun this gunk gets
from his buddy
don't be crazy you go in snatch the cash
get up
and we sell the pd to those psycho
freaks from the studio
got i got it you can only scan
clue during moments it's when it's
perceivable
the person recording in the brain dance
okay and remember
everything on full blast they'll spot us
extra for
okay okay right here
what do you want me to do [ __ ]
excellent
let's move on now heads up in analysis
mode
you can ferret out background noise and
conversations if the roller got close
enough this tech records everything
every little detail even the sights and
sounds the roller was never aware of
to see the sources of the recorded
sensory signals switch to the audio
layer in the editor
why am i doing this this is so lame
switch between available brain dance
layer
left shift i am
okay good now you should see several
sound signatures in the store
choose one and hone in on it
okay [ __ ] little [ __ ]
go restock i'll take the register how
about you suck a bag of dicks hey
so any thoughts bro i stopped editing
videos for a reason seriously
like what's happening right it's boring
yeah it's how bd recording implants work
they pick up everything all the elements
in the background
then an editor tweaks them makes them
pop keep playing with the sound
explore it a bit we'll move on when you
get bored okay now
sometimes you can analyze extra layers
in the raw stuff the rollers cyberware
picked up
like what ebb's got karoshi optics that
grab
infrared meaning you should be able to
grab heat signatures from her recording
hello nice yeah i was just about to say
guys
should i go inside
whoops
everybody on the ground you want to see
you kissing the flooring
scanning works on peeps too walk up to
the wounded chick
try scanning her i did all right next
thing scroll forward to the part where
our artist gets a lead injection
now we're able to [ __ ] drop you i
swear to god
whoa yeah now
before i pull your [ __ ] head off
see that they shot him and he never saw
it coming
but you will here it comes my favorite
part
of the game see the blinking thing over
the entrance
surveillance cam must have caught our
shooter
you'll see in a sec cam feeds to the
screen behind the clerk
roll back to where the screens in the
kids field of vision
then scan it
sorry i had just heard then scan it
is it the layer sorry i oh no i wasn't
listening
oh no
thank you
why can't i uh this screen
we saw the killer zoom in on that this
is some csi
[ __ ] probably all along
its
bd freaks are ready to pay a prem for a
real flatline
anyway if you've seen enough you can
exit
okay
thank you
yeah it's impressive right it's too bad
most of the bds we do here are only good
for flogging the log
flogging the logs look at your wreck
denoi let's take a break
still feel like that kid when
oh yeah i think i'm done
v there's no time get it together please
okay ah okay
running for my crew security specialist
she'll tell me what to look for while we
analyze
no problem i hope actually it is a
problem
not what we agreed as
judy t bugs are professional discreet to
a fault you can trust her
why cause you say so please
judy i'd never
expose you to any danger you know that
yo what the [ __ ] hey v
what's happening bug listen i got some
useful footage from kenpacki plaza
it's a brain dance kun peki
oh i thought as much someone there with
you
judy and evelyn they're chill
all right you gonna tell me what this is
about
listen need your help got no clue what
to look for once i'm in
all right see if i can walk you through
it jacking it to your tech now
you've got to give me access opening
port 1779
secure protocol good i'm going in
should be getting my requests now
got it you ready a millisecond
okay connection confirmed now some quick
tip ice
and we're clear ready to dance
fire up judy
i guess every game got to take his time
to explain what the [ __ ] it is
i get it am i a woman
what the [ __ ]
oh wow
i felt a fear sure got it under control
quick too
no they'll have that
then you shall perish for a good cause
but make yourself comfortable i
oh we're evelyn okay
is there anything we're supposed to scan
here in the beginning wait a minute
listen in on that conversation v could
be something important
i need a minute to finish the program is
still in the trial phase we cannot take
it to market as
is we shall see soon enough please speak
with your father
he's taken a particular interest in this
project he can certainly explain the
risks my father's the tired
visual this old grey beard who thinks
nothing will change
and he'll live forever in his tiny
frozen bubble i should not even be
listening to such things
you will listen to this sabroi is an
adult despot utterly removed from
reality
stuck in some fossilized vision of a
world
that no longer exists of a world that
may never have existed we have not seen
eye to eye for the past 20 years
i am quite sure we want now
read the documentation carefully the
relic requires specific storage
conditions
you must provide them yes heard that
relic docs got to be around here
somewhere look for them
relic talks i find no problem
relict nope
sorry to make you wait business
be stupid hmm it wasn't long
not even long enough for me to grow
bored is everything
all right you seem tense
edgy a moment it will pass
i can get to work on that just this is
weird
you wish to make demands of me
only one focus
okay on me oh got any candy
is that it no
[Music]
he's not he's using it what do you want
from me
scan his data pad he's holding it
bro very nice but come here already
what am i missing here
there's an alarm system by the elevator
it doesn't let me go anywhere
there it is
[ __ ] camera's packed with new tech
motion sensors heat sig activators
iff you skilled enough to kill it all
mucho more than enough mochimore
bedroom nightstand i got an idea
be right back
okay now we go back very nice but come
here already
just a sack looking for the perfect
thing
ah you'll like this
[Music]
there we go
it's loaded safety's on good to know
though once you're in there don't forget
about that iron
there we go
big brain [ __ ] details a special tip
controlled container
relic needs to be kept real cool so
chip's got to stay in the freezer
yep could damage it otherwise okay
switch on thermal layer detection in the
editor
thermal easier to spot where you are
know who's keeping the chip
well we got lights
got camera
we got action you have to rewind for
that maybe
it's in his pee pee it's pvc off the
chart
i miss this this is weird i know
we have to go back
nightstand i've got an idea be right
back
it has to be something here right
what am i missing here
thermal cl there thank you
air conditioning standard model for
hotels of this caliber
tip matches that stipulated in the docks
but no way the chip's hiding there
oh so too risky temp fluctuations risk
of damage
i gotta go back more
it's in the champagne ice bucket
challenge oh
donaghy's looks like mr arasaka had
something to celebrate
really think you'll find the chip in
there no way
tim's too low could fluctuate nice try
though
what's with the tens music like we're
not doing anything special
all right it's here in the fridge who
would have thought
just a fancy ass for you tip doesn't
match the guidelines won't find a thing
here
it's inside the computer
okay what am i missing here then
oh hello all right
grab the heatsink shut up recorder
master
i'm trying your nobody's got the case
here
guaranteed mm-hmm we got it good work
hey hey looks like we got everything we
need good out of the editor
with pleasure
yeah yep
that'll do judy we got it
later t-bug nice work today see you soon
thanks no one ever says that to me
can i shoot people now bang bang bing
bong
keep it i'll put it on ev's tab
portable device for handling bds
portable my own
settings not as sophisticated as what we
got here
but should do the trick and it keeps you
out of harm's way
clever speaking of harm's way
know what i see looking at you walking
talking corpses
relax i got it all under control
i got goof goopy goblin gamer brain
that's why i like hating so much evelyn
please no shortcuts
you go that route city you'll always win
so be careful
of course i will be besides we'll talk
in a bit
i was actually so glad when uh he
brought that up the goopy
goofy game of ram like it's not just me
who just wants to play the game
it just seems like everyone is always so
into the story like oh my god this story
so
no it isn't thanks for the help thanks
judy
really don't worry
i know what i'm doing
you could reply like you're welcome
[Music]
all right let's steal some [ __ ] she
won't know that's mine
what else you got in here
come on come on
so what now v
do this job for me i mean me alone
no splitting the payout with anyone else
no middlemen
no decks prologue is like firewires when
you meet kiana it starts to be sandbox
okay epic
if i agree they'll be hell to pay for
sure
i know whatever you decide
stays between us i can offer 50
oh eddie's enough whatever the hell you
like
i'll be finished dex won't forgive a
dirt move like this
dex isn't the only fixer in town but my
offer is the only one you'll ever get
let me think about it
if you need me call i'll send you my
number oh we got her number bros
hell yeah good luck now go
i need a few words with judy can i stay
i'm so
lonely
please please
[Music]
please
all right all right
[ __ ] my tits what did you say
i forgot how things
[Music]
what now now we do the job i hired you
to do
grabbing that violence we'll talk about
the rest at the afterlife
[Laughter]
my what a sweet little face to have
thank you kiss my dead spunk get that
day download
[Music]
they're the ones with the goofy gobbler
gamer brain not me
[Music]
[ __ ] wrong way
stop texting me
gotta fight for something would you know
don't judge me you're no american
all right
[Music]
can i not do anything in here
hey
successful meeting
what's on the menu
why yeah they have lemonade
machete yes
oh heck yeah can i sell him a bunch of
shitty guns
i can can i oh my god yeah
that's a cool looking gun
here you have all my crap now
and i will give you a slaughterhouse
jerky
increases max health by five
oh it only lasts for a certain time
so these are like buffs during combat
okay
thanks better get going
no g feel i'm not interested
no the other one say the line
kiss my dead spunk yay
going in or staying out getting the [ __ ]
out
all right off we go don't text and drive
excuse me
coming through changing lanes
[Music]
oh i gotta turn here
don't worry about it
the car here heals itself
is it quicker if i go here
perfect parking thank you
yes my tits punk don't push me
yeah about time holmes
what's new with senora wells
uh you know she's worried about me
whatever can't help herself you know
checking to see if i'm not riding in
some dumpster like most of the whales
boys
it's really starting to wear on me more
i tell her everything's okay
or i feel like i'm straight up lying i
like how his name is jack
and he's got the jack haircut after
tomorrow
and he has an accent it's the same guy
yeah nomad the afterlife's
known far and wide the afterlife
known far and wide that name oh yeah
some of the nomad clan's biggest jobs
are scored right here
don't surprise me ain't no better place
than night city to land a gig
ready to get your cherry popped yeah
wait what does that mean
what does that mean what does that mean
i don't want to get my cherry pot
no no
yes is that what cherry pop means
it's peeing right okay let's just pee
place used to be a morgue
you believe that who would have thunk
i know right way before our time that
the proper burials were still a thing
and who might you clowns
we're friends of dexter desean he's
expecting us
yo dex got two live ones saying they're
here to see you
yeah all right then
says he needs a second or two go get
yourselves drinks
how do you how do you even pop a cherry
it makes no sense
looks like we're up
i'm not googling it i'm not having that
[ __ ] in my search history
that's rogue best fixer in all of night
city
thought dex was the best
rogue was lining up jobs when dex was
still [ __ ] in diapers
place belongs to her what can i get you
you order two tequila fashions with a
splash of cerveza and a chili garnish
duo of johnny silverhands coming up
right on chica
somebody did their homework looks like
the dog ate mine
they wanted a drink named after me what
would i have to do
snuff it and blowingly spectacular
fashion
mid up would be best ah what a beautiful
tradition
i guess dying's a small price to pay for
going i'm doing the no alcohol route
i live like a legend first though huh
death
it'll pay off in the end trust me guys
oh [ __ ] nah [ __ ]
uh
uh did i make make a wrong choice
to somewhere filthy rich filthy rich
legends
oh i figured it out you could skip it
you want to write down my recipe oh
sure see on the rocks
lime juice ginger beer oh and most
importantly
a splash of love
i'll remember that i heard you were
dex's latest vines
just biz no big deal
you shouldn't see you now my job no one
cares
how do you think mercs are in their reps
gossip rivaling that of school girls
that's how
all right we're good we're good thank
you thanks
dude this game this game is so close to
cringe
it's so over the top it's kind of funny
like i really love it the art design is
so good it's kind of it's kind of like
you know
techwear the the clothing
style where people have like this
futuristic look but if you go too far in
it
it can look stylish but if you go far
it's just like really cringe
and i feel like this game is treading
that line of like
future cyber punk
it's going very near just close enough
though i do like it
damn holmes you're huge work out
thanks bro same here no in the ring
you do some kind of exotic [ __ ] huh
kenpo ninjutsu
um think you could take me drop me
in here
cringe punk 2077.
there it is
that's right excelsior
cold-hearted it's a good idea gotta
bounce
surprise someone's done it earlier i
took it
whole family in one place yeah look at
that
what the [ __ ] first time in real space
and the flathead
let's see this bad boy
oh uh with the flight
i did it there you go in you go boy
all right set your butts down comfy
thanks for your help back at the scav
haunt a few reapers less in the city
good thing city hall should be [ __ ]
thanking us
yes i have to sit sweet booth
is soundproof jackie
now now mr wells is right we're gonna be
going over some sensitive material
but if it's all right with y'all i'd
like to start with a question for mr v
evelyn parker how'd you fare
well as i could have i guess walked
around kenpecki plaza inside
from that role i think defeat is the
best part of the game so far
bug already filled me in so you know the
target
you're a nobu arisaka the emperor's son
and heir apparent
man with the millionaire name and no
talent to back it up
evelyn parker's special friend he's got
good toast you know i just want to see
what's good or
was there something else
so i can use this should i try that
chick i don't know
sent out mixed signals so i got mixed
feelings
one night sipping sham paradise with the
oronobu
next night chatting up with regulars at
lizzie's yeah we're doing a barefoot run
don't match up it will pay off india and
trust me
you guys we putting two and two together
and getting five
some part of the equation's missing then
clearly
that's why y'all got a fixer anyone try
to [ __ ] you
they first gotta [ __ ] their way through
decks to sean's 300-pound ass
what the anything else children close
your eyes
there was something else parker made me
another offer
yes close your ears
kind where we ditched the middleman and
split the pot in even 50 50.
what ditch the middleman
[ __ ] she
clients never learn do they smooth man
smooth i do appreciate you sharing this
info though mr b
you see trust is essential in any
partnership that's to be long
lasting and fruitful
how about we go over the plan what you
got
this sorry squeeze my tits punk
well i keep forgetting what the [ __ ] she
says me and dex have already covered the
fine deep
ops wise should be a stroll on the beach
the library
i want to hear it a delamane will drop
your asses at the front door of kenpecki
plaza you'll stroll right in thanks to
your false identities
then with bugs help you'll breach the
hotel subnet
he's my kids fun last but not least
you slip into your no-boos penthouse and
clep the relic
it goes without saying we do this on the
hush
second not a one you'll have t-bug on
comms for the duration
time for your burning questions all
clear to me
perfect i got a question where do we get
to the real reason we're all here
good thank you thank you that's a good
year
fresh talent gets 30 always
but i'm willing to make an exception in
your case
i'ma cut you a nice juicy 40 as a bonus
for your honest tv
appreciate it dex even though the yetis
aren't most important to me
interesting so what does qualify as most
i
i didn't pick my dollar sign so i'm
doing a no pp run
thanks for asking the recorder always
look at you youngins making us
all [ __ ] look bad
last thing kenpecki's got a strict no
iron policy
security gates the works so you dogs
will leave your leg spitters in the ride
take the flathead inside in its case
got some deft suits so you'll look the
part too
thanks t so not to count chickens but
why don't we see our eddies all depends
how miss parker avails herself of her
role
but a week two tops is my guess
what do we do while waiting sit around
suck air
you sit tight heads down cause old uncle
arisa could be watching
now as that old greek dog says life's a
banquet so don't go thirsty but don't
get drunk i like it you can see his
belly button through this shirt
my cue to delta two got a prep to jack
in be there when you come on comms
any other issues now's your chance
i'm good no questions let's get to work
so you ready to get going or what
something i got to take care of first
sim problems
meet you by the dollar bean problems
why why is spanish people the only
people that
mix english and spanish don't forget to
suit up
if i just randomly start going in a
problem
people will be like what the [ __ ] are
you saying right why can't spanish
people go
get away with it it's [ __ ] all right
i'm do it y'all got it for new
toronto news what do you think
yeah swedish is cool i can do it
because it sounds cool well it sounds
cool when i do it in swedish too
right bro legs nice legs
very nice where do you get them
is food ready okay guys
it's the favorite part of the live
stream where i go and have lunch
and i also have to help march that with
the thing
so i'll be a little longer but i'll be
right back
okay just sit tight
have a snack
[Applause]
i got some music in the bag
i'm still hungry
one second
back to where you came from
[Applause]
thanks sorry
don't back down guys
i bought coffee this morning it's all
cold
oh they put milk in it shootings have
been reported
who puts milk in their coffee what kind
of sociopath
it feels a bit like a mirror's edge when
you stand on top of buildings
first person that's still one of my
favorite games ever
i mean to hit map but i keep hitting
[ __ ]
and it's like this future wait a minute
enter the dalai dela main which floor is
the de la main
i'm on the roof for no reason
ah
yeah espresso is best americana always
burns my tongue that's why i don't drink
it right away
here we are
so really i just want to go back to my
place
oh sick look at the back oh what the
[ __ ]
i got twitter blocked on my computer
oh yeah you all have to tell me what
about that time i wanted to hire you for
my cousin's bachelor party huh
unfortunately we do not take on such
contracts
three months i've been saving off
scratch
yeah water under the bridge hit it
though
before we begin our journey i must
verify the identities of all customers
ah [ __ ] i'm not barefoot
all right let's jack it up
thank you excelsior package activated
excelsior oh this just keeps getting
better
you need to mute all music
uh you know what [ __ ] it
it's so nice i don't want to ruin the
experience
for a copyright who gives a [ __ ] i don't
need the money
excelsior the excelsior is a package
tailored to our premium clientele
top quality don't come free you know now
watch
delamade initiate combat mode my
apologies
but you do not appear to be in any sort
of imminent danger
huh oh well
trust me this is nice slow down an army
of soccer ninjas if it comes down to it
dex ain't skimping is he he ain't simply
neither thanks to you we're still
getting a juicy 40
you're welcome
excelsior this is how you want to cruise
into the major leagues
is that really your be-all and end-all
huh
dex managed to buy you off that cheap
with a suit
a limo no jack kind of feels like you're
losing that steel grip of yours
huh seems to me like it's you who's got
some kind of problem
i need you to keep your head clear and
in the game we got a job to do it's
never
ever been clear in my whole [ __ ] life
let me explain something to you fee we
are nearing our destinations
hey how's things smooth as [ __ ]
sandpaper
we'll be uh pulling up to the hotel soon
listen
set up a direct encrypted line to guide
you through kompecki
the ring jackie now see if we're in sync
can't be too careful
got static say something bug the
greatest crimes
issue from a desire for excess and not
from necessity
say what now aristotle i guess you read
me then
yeah wait what not so much your greek
friend
though it was kind of exciting give it
some thought
try to understand how about juvie
give me hit me up with that here oh i
can't i don't have enough in
oh what a lame read you loud and clear
perfect
okay tech checks out looks like
stay in touch someone said marcus
aurelius is in the
mansion in the game
[Music]
lame dude let me [ __ ] shoot something
harry
let's go
anyone hold on
let me grab the flathead
cool place
[Music]
we're out front bug remember
reservations in your name
ramon military tech department
papers are for the flat head welcome to
competition there's a kojima
easter egg if you go inside the in the
bar go inside and go to the left
but this looks japanese inspired
please come through single file you got
it
sir that looks like an uncomfortable
couch
hold on got something sir
care to explain why you're bringing a
combat bot onto kenpecki plaza premises
we're arms dealers excuse me
ah you are here to see pakistan am i
right
please accept my apologies for the
confusion
inhabitant
this should only take a moment sir
go ahead all right the bar to the left
and welcome to kon peki
we'd like to check in of course
just a moment please the name on the
reservation is
victorino double room two adults
one night correct that's the one
perfect i'll go ahead and notify
pakistan over arrival
[ __ ] no good not part of the plan talk
her up v
stall oh uh
that won't be necessary we'll go freshen
up first
notify him ourselves but
wait we gotta check in first
do you know how long we've been
traveling 18 hours from new barcelona
with the delay on meta-key because some
cyber cycle blew himself into bits
inside the terminal
uh a nightmare of course i understand
you'll be in the loftiest leslie suite
la pizza julie my gamer
oh one more little phone got that
enchanted [ __ ]
validate your s-i-d-chip
hunter's all yours harry
everything seems to be in order we wish
you a pleasant stay
thanks thank you thank you better get
going
it's called improvising you should try
it if anything
you can take your [ __ ] i'm bouncing on
that
part of the news
i'm bouncing i can't stand still
kamikaze
ah bruh
there he goes
all right let's get going
where's the bar then what do you think
harry
hmm quaint cozy
not like the hotel we had in zurich damn
looks insane
don't need that jack enough what
i've taken this seriously
be one and only how were you able to
seduce the world's most
expensive model
i have a bunch of text messages
here's the bar
bar don't look too shabby yeah let's
check it out welcome to kenpecki plaza
welcome to reservations weekday so feel
free to grab any available table
or a couple of stools at the bar if you
prefer could bring misty here one day
when we uh close this deal take a peek
inside
it's a stereo
i'll check out the bar okay
what do you want a private jet from
school yes my dad's fun
i
[Music]
confirmed
please leave me in peace and when i say
heads are going to roll
i don't mean it as a [ __ ] turn of
phrase
had enough guy don't you think there he
is
hey
cool
[Music]
not cool
all right let's get going that's cool
there we have it
why this
that's what i mean with the game being
like close to cringe
it's like you got this and then when
when you're in combat there's like 500
overlays on everything which is kind of
fun
in a way but it's also
hey we got some fishies
we're in our room whoa pretty snazzy
too bad we ain't staying the night nice
choice book
didn't pick it for snazz offers quickest
access to the dweller and servers
now you fire up the flathead and find
the shaft entrance sounds simple enough
it's implicit gotcha sometimes toughest
to master aurelius
who's it this time hey aurelius there
you go what's mine
where's the shaft boot up your scanner
look around
i'm more of an epic tedious kind of guy
you know
what did i just do i called the car
which one is photo mode again it's n
isn't it
that's right how you can't
why would i have okay
sure whatever look better without all
the filter
still nothing come on can't be that hard
got a winner good jackie
oh my bad i didn't mean to escape
just going to stand there and look at it
you can pose like jojo no way
take the control you can pause like jojo
foreign
uh
[Music]
hell yeah
to surveillance so you can guide the bot
here here goes
men of culture made this game philosophy
references jojo references
god respected
and the women to work on game sorry guys
caught myself there
arasaka will cover the cost any and all
penalties assist
bro i think i got the money it's
election season
how do you think this will make me look
people start saying i've lost control of
watson
district i'm from
sawing some metal i think i got in my we
will try
what's it called eyelid it's been
hurting all morning
i'm [ __ ] bing bong
i was like sewing metal better close my
eyes
okay flat heads in patching you into
next cam now
what makes you think it was for you he
addressed us in a kind household
bug got a hitch said no sorry for them
you gotta distract them
nope i'd say keep looking terrarium's
got a temp an air quality controller
crane yeah stick the flat head on it who
do you know good looking filthy rich
has that naughty look in his eye he's
staying in the penthouse
i mean you're a noble arasaka men like
him are always single
might wear expensive suits but he's a
biker at heart
always itching for a ride i listened a
little bit to the new lady it's really
good so far
i only listened to songs
so far yeah it's on the top of my eyelid
it's fine
yes i ain't seen nothing yet you got any
idea how much those things cost
keep moving no time for back patton
is is irritating
there we go
i don't have the glasses
go where's it going
you guys would actually go to the
hospital for that
bro now when you get older what is
happening
scan away into the i am in the vent
i was not scanning sorry
i'll just remove my eye i saw it in the
game guys
looks like he's having trouble [ __ ]
gotta be another way
let me think i've got another cam other
side of the door but it's disabled
want me to enable yeah look around for a
cctv port
[Music]
okay he's at it now toggle over to the
other cam
already ahead of you [ __ ] inside just
as planned
the hotel's only got one runner decent
dwellers as good as a dozen rank and
file
flathead ought to be able to neutralize
good thinking
thank you thank you and you know you
gotta jack the flat head directly into
his chair
right make it sound like i'm new at this
okay scent
you'll have to get the flat head in
there first though i'm just
hacking i'm whacking i'm smacking oh
yeah
let's figure it out now toggle over to
the other cam
i found our way in send the flathead
over there then toggle over to the
second
jack in
i love that red overlay it looks cool
almost star warsy
oh got him love those demons
flathead stays right to keep an eye on
the dweller yeah
punching into kompecki's main alien [ __ ]
little dizzy that's all bug
how you doing on time
you there bug yeah yeah i'm here
so listen ice is thicker than i thought
piercing it'll take a couple hours
a couple hours can't do it any faster
want my brain to burst into flames yes
just sit down and enjoy your snazzy
suite
thanks i will v
you take it easy okay
are we almost at keanu
come on what can we do in the hotel
room
switch on the tel aviv tel avi
it's only adds my favorite channel
explosion of taste nope
never fade away
oh it's
drama news my favorite
news
in twin what
oh i gotta sit my bed
the good life i mean old news i know
just got to thinkings all it's like
think you got everything right
at ease education your pops can snap his
fingers and
turn half the [ __ ] planet into a
nuclear wasteland
but instead you're like ah [ __ ] it what
do you go do
start a [ __ ] gang yeah steal dragons
or some [ __ ]
you ghost from your fam real skin
and play gang leader for a few years for
what
no man maybe one addict damn he just
wanted out of the system
so then why do you come back one wee one
me all right i'll meet you a russian boy
it's your own family
black sheep still one way to put it
crawl back on all fours tail between his
legs
[ __ ] cheap ass rebel
[ __ ] tourist tourist or not he just
walked into the lobby
okay good and we are back in biz
penthouse security is neutralized
perfecto let's start the show oh there
you perfect
let's start the show we're uh
are you on comes that whole time three
and a half hours
about that stick up the ass mean the one
of mine
the slip of the tongue you know i know
now's your chance to make up to me
once kiana shows up it gets more
interesting i hope so at least
this is very uh generic i would say it
feels extremely generic the story
there's the awkward side we only had
like two fighting scenes so far
now seriously it's a bit awkwardly paced
i would say
i'm here for the details and the design
i think that's what makes it interesting
if it wasn't this
fleshed out i think i would be really
hating it
but this keeps me in sure is [ __ ] better
than being a son
guys focus the safe many
many
what is he a [ __ ] sorcerer some kind
of dead zone's my guess happen back in a
sec
and you do your damn job there under the
floor
under the floor eh
i didn't go corporal i'm no man
i did it what now
check in your personal and make us rich
on it
your turn bug give me two
we got winged visitors bug
don't know who but staff's a buzz all
200 on their feet can't keep still
i can't say i like this no worries
how much longer t [ __ ] you're a know
who's penthouse bound
[ __ ] here open the scene almost got it
all right we knew he packed the iron
good let's go why can't i walk
mine [ __ ] too late was about to walk in
find cover
where that pillar try that you [ __ ]
kidding
no inside it now
[Music]
we're in which don't solve our problem t
i [ __ ] know our problem's still there
let me think for a sec okay
did we go bang bang i thought i don't
smash her oh
god
[ __ ] are they talking about
who we got incoming no [ __ ] way
this isn't happening saburo arasaka
the emperor yet another ass-licking
legend josh
thought this could be soundproof
oh no adam smasher
now that's a sexy [ __ ]
is that was that
what's that
oh [ __ ] no it isn't
too close vida sniffed us out
but he did it
guys stop talking for the love of god a
man's got a [ __ ] missile launcher on
his back
[Music]
foreign
do you think they'll hear if i play
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
no more lockdowns please no
attention but he did it we saw it
please remain in your rooms and follow
all instructions
given by staff
what a stinky liar
he would be good at among us i gotta i
gotta hand it to him
there was no poison i didn't see any
poison
at all dude i'll already grab the gun
why does he have the valve logo on him
[Music]
what the [ __ ] just happened in there
security's gonna swarm the place any
second oh my god we're so [ __ ]
bug need to get us out all right this is
it i mean i'm aiming for this [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh okay
releasing the lock should see a ladder
ladder open [ __ ]
oh no no no no not now
she's been made what does that mean
[ __ ] what does that mean happy now
jackie
yeah that's [ __ ] high
you can just slide down you're making no
problem
see that trauma if they're here for
saburo they're a little late
just hope they didn't see us
[Music]
hey i told you bro you just jumped this
is like mirror's edge
i'll be smalley
[Music]
good
jackie you're bleeding worry about me
later
check the relic container depressurized
mild chip integrity at 94
that's pretty good
uh that's bad what does karasho mean
quick
parker caller spanish brothers
just do it
that's a creepy ass girl
what the [ __ ] is going on there got a
problem
cryo case is damaged it means potato
chips integrity
86 86 and drop it [ __ ]
okay listen there's only one thing you
can do
one of you've got to slot the relic into
your neural port
that doesn't sound safe the longer you
wait the greater the risk will lose it
well someone's got to do it
jabla fan carajo
[Applause]
hey cyberpunk hit me up cd product red
do you want me to do the soundtrack
i guess
we're working on it yeah we're on it
[ __ ]
dale we'll be there in a couple
be ready you got it certainly mr wells
thank you better be [ __ ] certain oh
[Music]
bro don't shoot yourself just be quick
uh there might be a shower nearby
we'll find you one don't worry follow me
i got you bro
oh great a shower right there bro you
can sit right there
where's my [ __ ] gun can i not pull it
out
okay there you are my buddy
[Music]
got to be stealth here
okay so i'm hacking i'm hacking
what am i looking for bd or one c
[Music]
where are they
dead and dead just get dead and death
[Music]
see it sounds cool when i say it in
swedish right
oh there's one more [ __ ]
i'm trying a headshot
peepee shot oh he dropped something
oh i'll take that
take that [ __ ] finally some
action baby let's go
don't overheat me bro
where is he i can't [ __ ] see
he has no rights
but neither do you [ __ ]
i thought i was dead hell yeah
[ __ ]
as i was done [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] funny hump
focus come on uh just gotta change
weapon here
give me two seconds do i not have any
ammo
no ammo all right
i'm here for you
give me ammo
fight
whoa what the [ __ ]
thank you
all right give me their [ __ ] ammo
i don't have my knife for some reason
i think one of them dropped a shotgun
yeah
reload thing
attention
so grenades are someone said was middle
mouse but
is there a quick way to access weapons a
quick button f r t
q alt alt
got it okay
status effect so we have a bunch of like
[ __ ] don't we this is crafting
i want my inventory
can we eat these
yo we had a gold chain i want to drink
the soup
hold your fire
how do i throw the nade it doesn't work
we're not
[ __ ]
don't peak
can't hit me you can't hit me i'm too
fast
well i almost died
very nice that's what i'm here for the
the grouper goblin gable marine is
satisfied
atlanta all right quick access so now we
have
no i want to change you out how do i
foxy
he dropped the he dropped the [ __ ] i
saw it he dropped the
baseball bat am i holding it no it's a
shotgun
did i think a shotgun was a baseball bat
was i did i just see did i just see
things
all right that's a sexy looking gun by
the way we'll bring a snack
how you doing buddy
do i have attachment i do yeah i have a
scope
nice maybe i should put that on the smg
nah that's dumb
[Music]
hey
what'd you say to me what the flip did
you say to me
stay down stay there good one
shotgun is good hey you died in a sexy
position i threw an
eight i did it
peepee shot peepee shut bp
hey point for you
thank you
how am i not [ __ ] hitting him
[ __ ]
clean
nice this gun is amazing
i like this it's fun
[Music]
right gotta press the button
you're fine bro you're fine
150 years
dude if we write him out we get 10 bucks
should we do it
new item what the [ __ ] is that
excuse me
we have so many guns what is that oh
i like you call this funny oh okay
your liver could be [ __ ] uh not his
liver
after a night of drinking dude that gun
looks so aesthetic i love the look of it
tamara but the other one is so much
better
oh we can put scope on all of these now
not on that all right had it coming
but
we'll get you a new liver bro why
because you [ __ ] say so
don't take this out on me yeah honestly
that was [ __ ] move
i can't believe i pressed that
hey
oh excess grenade isn't it and then
middle mouse button it's
[ __ ] i'm so dumb i'm so [ __ ] down
[ __ ] i took a lot of damage
bro you're peaking this thing does no
damage
owie
[Music]
where you going son
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i gotta reload bro it's so slow
ah i'm out of ammo i reloaded for no
ammo
i'm not dying here oh [ __ ] um
be right back right back
they're shocking me
let's get the handgun where's my [ __ ]
handgun
why aren't they shooting me
oh my god
careful me i got you
stop moving stop moving
that was a headshot
whoa [ __ ] this i ain't got the ammo
bro let me loop first thank you
we have seven more shots
the [ __ ] gates cheating
all right this is what the vikings did
before a battle
yes yes yes
oh no
[ __ ] it did nothing i did nothing
i gotta hack him
i could just hack him [ __ ]
oh i could just hack him
it did nothing all right we gotta get
behind him
we gotta get behind him it's an old
trick
i'm dead i died all right don't go
behind him i think you're just supposed
to run
past him i think [ __ ] it just hit me
[Music]
no all right fine
wait wait wait wait i got a new item
action blocked [ __ ]
i'm going the wrong way holy [ __ ]
you think they start at the bottom of
the elevator what the [ __ ]
[Music]
what
sorry gamers that was a big [ __ ] up my
bag
years and today
i've gone all in melee all
[Laughter]
there's a perk that gets health during
that one yeah yeah that seems worth it
okay yeah that seems worth it
i'm not cool i'm not i'm not cool
this is funny yeah i do
your liver could be [ __ ] had it coming
but she'll be
we'll get on alive i'll save the names
for the mech yeah
why because you [ __ ] say so don't
take this out on me
let's go
this gun sucks
[ __ ] i took a lot of them bro you're
peaking
i want to get a head shot
i swear they move their heads like every
time i shoot him
see
[Music]
no
[Applause]
oh it's right [ __ ] there
how much i would need like a billion
ammo for this
i'm not dying
oh he's there
i'm out of ammo
oh craig
i'm out of nades
come on almost there
yeah legs
legs
you better drop something good
[Music]
nice
when he dropped the
what do you drop that one wasn't it
assault rifle
oh sexy
gonna make it bro we're gonna make it
get in
bro we're almost at the shower
celebration flute you're right
thank you
what the [ __ ] are they shooting each
other
uh they have a lot of help
i don't need to know what model car i
have
this gun sucks dude
am i not hitting him how
peak [ __ ] it cannot be
it's me [ __ ]
careful now
stop moving your head what am i hitting
just died
no i'm not
hopefully we go on the bikes that'd be
sick
coming for you [ __ ]
let's go
that handgun is a beast
i want their loot
give me the loot should i help my buddy
out
yeah he's fine
got it welcome back
you don't [ __ ] cry
not client bad noted
how's our ride looking tip top though
alas
we are being pursued oh
oh oh [ __ ]
leave it at me this gun though
let me just reload let me just reload
let me just reel
oh
easy
ain't doing [ __ ]
phew
we did it jackie we [ __ ] made it [ __ ]
yeah
i guess we did my medical diagnostics
indicate that mr wells's condition
take us through river dock now pronto
put some fun
in our itinerary has been pre-arranged
and paid for in advance
i am not at liberty to alternate [ __ ]
your liberty do what i say
it's okay
[Music]
i suggest you try to keep mr wells
conscious
it's gonna be all right huh you'll see
misty your mom
everyone you love jackie don't close
your eyes
jackie no you were like a father to me
misty i should know
you always know
bro no don't do it
for me hey don't put that in me that's
gay oh
okay fine you know what fine put it in
me
thanks bro
oh jackie bro
no i will play the song in his honor
[Music]
nowhere stay here and don't move
i'll be right back unbelievable jackie
seeing the major leagues jack oh
[Music]
secure era use of force permitted
annihilation
we level up and [ __ ] handguns seems
uh like a good choice
i'm gonna save there i actually have to
get going that was a cool end though
damn i'm
again i'm liking the game a lot now that
was the my gamer gobblegum
brain gamer brain is satisfied at last
yes
what do you guys reckon
very nice very nice
thanks for watching another live stream
i'll see you guys tomorrow in morrigon
for more cyberpunk
thanks for joining guys have a have a
best time have the best time
yeah professors
you